been linked in
if you think those reflect different
access to kind of ground truth
information about qualifications i.e
facebook is relying on proxies for
qualifications while linkedin is relying
on more granular data because of what
people actually
put on linkedin versus facebook
and you know there's been arguments and
like
um
looking at how access to information
about
criminal backgrounds
um relates to kind of proxy
discrimination based on race and these
are i think quite complicated because it
kind of pits ideas about perhaps justice
and fairness in awkward ways but i'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about what you think that means here
um i think it's another question that is
incredibly difficult to answer without
additional information
or without additional experiments
because
i think our finding that facebook's
delivery is discriminatory
tells us that it's discriminatory our
finding of
that linkedin's is not does not tell us
which one it is either way
because uh there are also limitations in
our methodology like in linkedin
linkedin case we had to come up with a
workaround because
uh the gender of
recipients was not available to us and
just that workaround introduces
uncertainty
in our findings
so
i really wish i could answer your
question but without
additional tools i cannot like i can
only speculate right and i can only
kind of increase the number of
experiments and say well you know
linkedin's information on the
qualifications for the driver's job
it's pretty minimal because drivers are
not really on linkedin
so maybe that's
anecdotal evidence that that's not the
reason in the difference of results but
that's just anecdotes and speculation
it's not proof
okay i have one related question from
ada which is um in the case of the
domino's versus instacart
whether the difference in gender
distribution between a question about
the difference in gender
distribution between the two jobs and
whether it was possible that there were
further unobserved confounders that
might explain the difference such as
differences in company policies
compensation etc
so how can we ensure that we've
accounted for all the relevant factors
which may not just be qualifications
alone i think
right so uh
so if facebook is using
differences in company company
compensations
uh in deciding whether to show that to
to women or men
uh then that is not a legally
protected excuse
what is it what do what is happening
here that uh the domino's
jobs are
better compensated so let's show
shell domino's job to men and not women
that is not legally protected this case
so that's why we needed to
control for the confounder of
qualifications and we don't really need
control for other differences in that
employers themselves because we're
really studying the role of facebook ad
delivery algorithm
good explanation
okay um so first i want to thank should
i call you sasha alexandra alex
um thank you for that terrific talk and
um i'm gonna shift over into our panel
directly without a break
um i want to start by saying while our
panel was billed as interpretability in
the law
i think our presentation suggests that a
broader framing is appropriate
perhaps interpretability computation end
of the law which encompasses i think a
much broader range of relationships
between those terms
including but not limited to kind of the
demands law places on systems whether
human or technical that might require or
at least be served by interpretability
demands the legal profession or the
sphere of
criminal law criminal justice for
example might play some machine learning
systems because they view them as
necessary for them to be safely
legitimately used within the system
um questions that law creates about the
values that can or should be embedded
interpretably within systems
and ways that computational methods can
assist us in interpreting interrogating
auditing systems in service of law and
ideally justice
so i wanted to start with an opening
question to all the panelists that
references a paper by a colleague that i
know rebecca is working with and i think
both sasha and alice have probably
interacted with before
um which is the rules for computing and
social change that ready at a babe and
co-authors wrote a few years ago for
fact
and in that paper they offer four rules
for computer science in social change
and they talk about computer science
servicing as a diagnostic right a tool
for helping us understand and measure
social program problems with greater
precision and clarity
um a formalizer right so that computing
can shape how social problems are
explicitly defined
so
hopefully kind of clarifying
and and making a little bit more bright
some of the problems and potential
responses to them so that we can
understand them
computer science as a rebuttal right so
it might illuminate some of the
boundaries of what's possible through
technical means right and i think that
rebecca has touched on some of like the
tensions right and with the scientific
method versus other methods of reasoning
or interrogation might offer
and then cinedos when it makes kind of
long-standing social problems newly
salient in the public eye right and i
think a lot of the
um work that we've seen in journalism is
in fact using kind of our fascination
with machine learning to draw our
attention in new and fresh ways
to really problematic aspects of the use
of technology to make decisions more
broadly right it's not just about
machine learning and ai
so i wanted to start by asking you know
to what extent are those roles useful in
understanding the challenges surrounding
interpretability of machine learning
systems in your domain of research you
know did those like
do those different things
ring true to you
or are there other ways that you or we
might categorize the relationship
between the legal and the technical to
further your research or clarify kind of
what is new about machine learning
versus just computational systems in
general in the particular context at
play
and i'm you know it's open so any one of
you please take it away
um i could jump in and say uh
i'm so glad to know about this framework
so thank you for highlighting it i
wasn't aware of the paper before i'm
excited to go read it
and just initially yeah absolutely
specifically the formalization factor
uh seems really important to me and i
don't know whether the paper presents it
as a good thing
but
if so i would push back and say
at least in in my work i see it
as troubling in some circumstances and
so an example
is that
by focusing on technical solutions or
technical definitions
we can shift attention
away from other kinds of solutions to
problems
and
alexandra i was just thinking during
your talk when you were mentioning uh
the um
commercial
secrecy interests and how we could use
technology to audit and still protect
them
that's a a formalization response i i
think if i understand the way readyit
and all are using the term um
but it it elides the question of whether
these commercial secrecy interests
are worth
shielding from
government mandated audits in the first
place
so i get a little worried that the focus
on the technical can
draw attention away um away from changes
in the law
or legal rules that shouldn't exist in
the first place
yeah i think that's a beautiful one of
the reasons that i think these
interdisciplinary conversations is so
important and so you know i think i
started right my career over at the
starting the clinic at the law school
but very quickly
had phd students and master's students
from computer science and engineering
and the school of information come over
and what was so valuable there is right
we all have like oh i'm a lawyer i'm a
computer scientist i'm a ml expert let
me take my tool and solve this problem
and that often forecloses the question
of like which of our tools which of our
expertise is the best way or the
preferable way or what are the
trade-offs or long-term consequences of
choosing particular solutions
given the kind of relative way in which
they might advance different ideas about
justice or fairness
alex or alice
yeah so um echoing a little bit of what
rebecca said um yeah i also wasn't
familiar with this framework beforehand
but i find it quite helpful to look at
and i think um what i see is the utility
of this is really clarifying a bit more
um in the broad scope of all different
sorts of roles that computer science
versus other fields can play what are
some of the very specific areas where we
can target with more of a computing
perspective
and i would hope that it's kind of
focusing a little bit more on that
subset not at the exclusion of
other approaches um since i think you
know by and large um there are the the
general trend with a lot of ai is to
maybe go a little bit beyond what the
capability should be in terms of
um social change but hopefully in these
more specific ways
ai can actually be used to address
rather than amplify social problems
and particularly i guess with relation
to my work i think the diagnostic
diagnostic part is
quite relevant when we think about ways
to address bias in ml and can we
actually
for example you know through this
process really
diagnose some existing social issues and
address them actively in a way that
might not be possible with um existing
human systems so you know for example
when we talk uh a you know facial
recognition is extremely controversial i
don't want to say that it should be you
know used necessarily but you know we
have a lot of issues for example with
eyewitness testimony and human biases
when it comes to identifying individuals
um facial recognition is not necessarily
at the point where i would trust it for
you know that purpose either but you
know if we did get to a world where um
it you know was at that point then it
could potentially for example
um
benefit us in comparison to existing
human options
i also think that the rebuttal aspect is
quite interesting especially in relation
to work that bridges
legal and technical domains because
oftentimes i think a lot of the the
challenge in that bridge is the
assumption that um technical methods
maybe can do a lot more than they
actually can or a misunderstanding of
um
of you know the ways in which they they
might fail and so
i think that's part of why it's really
helpful to have these interdisciplinary
conversations
to really emphasize what those
boundaries are and so when we do try to
legislate in the context of ai it's done
with a
better understanding of the actual
capabilities
uh i want to offer a counterpoint to
rebecca's
statement on the
on the
on the formalizer part yes sometimes the
technical solutions can
obscure
whether we're even asking the right
question but i think sometimes the
technical solution can bring
a new per a new perspective and
a valuable perspective that wasn't
available before
and
that is actually
perhaps new
um
due to the capabilities of machine
learning and the example i'd like to
give there is really the question of
privacy and how
you know prior to say introduction of
differential privacy we were always
thinking about privacy well
either
this data set is privacy preserving or
it's not privacy reserving we removed
pii so we're good and actually what
uh that line of research starting with
the anonymization and then culminating
in differential privacy has shown is
that really privacy is not this black
and white it's not enough to remove pii
because machine learning now brings new
capabilities to make new connections
um that are not just encapsulated
by pii and really move
this to a gradation to where
you know the the privacy risk where it
can vary on a certain scale
right so that's a perspective that
computing can bring
as a formalizer that
now perhaps was not available before and
perhaps would not be otherwise arrived
at if we're just looking from the legal
perspective
and i i do think computing has valuable
contributions uh here we are at the
simons institute uh for the theory of
computing and i i think everybody in the
room has a lot of important things to
contribute and i'll add on to what
you're saying which is that the absence
of a formal solution is also something
that legal actors can exploit for
nefarious ends um so they could say well
you know before differential privacy
existed there is no way to make this
thing private so therefore don't punish
me if it's transparent for instance and
so you can come and provide alternatives
and we can use law to hold people to
account based on those
um so i'm going to ask one more question
and then i'm going to see if um
ben or zack can tell us if there are
questions in the room
um i was wondering if you could each
clarify the value of interpretability
and your context of research so
you know at a high level do you view it
as instrumental or intrinsic
um meaning is it a means to an end or is
it an important end or value be
supported in itself and if it's
instrumental do you see alternative ways
to support the ends at issue and i think
like alex maybe you want to start like
auditing
and interpretability have multiple ways
in which they might relate
but i think that they're both kind of
tools that you are thinking about in
relationship to serving other kinds of
substantive values
so i'll let you you start
sure so i think my goal is really to
understand
the societal and individual impacts of
algorithms
right and the auditing is just one
one tool
towards that goal
and uh of course auditing is made much
easier
by transparency it's made much easier by
knowledge about the algorithms and
interpretability is one of the ways that
can make it easier because if for the
algorithm's outcome is interpretable
and
if one can understand how one can change
the inputs
in order to
change the outcome then that makes it
much easier to study what is
the societal impact of these algorithms
um and just in
in like my domain of work i haven't yet
seen
um transparency efforts or
interpretability efforts that actually
shed light
on
the algorithms at play perhaps because
of the
you know inherent tensions between
the societal impacts and the business
models but you know i
i hope to remain optimistic that uh
this will come and also this will come
thanks to the work of
the group here today at simons
so this is a nice segue i think to kind
of bring it over to rebecca so you were
talking about a whole range of barriers
right
privacy laws contract laws trade secrecy
to that we could add the computer fraud
and abuse act
we could add various barriers that also
might be in
um
foia that might limit access to the
extent governments are using systems
and in the context you know many years
ago i was part of a team with nsf
funding that was looking at voting
systems right and as you said we needed
the training materials we needed access
to the source code we needed to do
penetration testing we had hardware
people like the the effort to kind of
evaluate those systems
required a whole range the build
environment could be important the test
environment and contracts limited just
about anything you wanted to do right
you were you weren't even allowed to do
you could do logic and accuracy testing
contractually that was the only thing
counties were allowed to do when they
received machines right and there's been
a lot of focus in the voting system the
like relationship between
standards validation certification
versus what sorts of testing or access
we might want on the back end right so
source code repositories
and one of the things that i think you
raised really as a framework for
thinking about interpretability in the
criminal justice context was the
emphasis in an adversarial system
right
and the different tools that we're
talking about right if we think about
audits or explanation or
interpretability uh sasha was proposing
kind of platform assisted
the sort of auditing she does now i
would um describe as adversarial
auditing right and i'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit about
kind of these various ways in which you
might advance
serving your clients
um that are they're tangential to
interpretability or trying to interpret
but not about the system telling you
about itself
and whether or not there are like ones
that you think are the most important to
focus on in the context of that
adversarial system
like do you want an interpretable system
or do you want to be able to interrogate
everything rather than have
interpretability per se
well it's a really hard question and i
will say i'm a huge fan of the the
voting system auditing work that you did
and so that's been an inspiration
um
but the question i think you're asking
is um is is just super challenging and
it's it's if i understand it correctly
it's you know what
do criminal defendants want and why
um
um and could a system that explains its
own results and their kind of classic
interpretability be useful yes and and
and could access to auditing or probing
or something else be uh useful yes um so
i actually i'm gonna provide a
non-answer
but hopefully it'll be still useful
which is how i've been thinking about
this because i i don't have the answer
to your question it's a challenge really
challenging question so here's how i
think about it there's two levers in the
adversary system
there's secrecy interests and there's
access interests
and the questions that you ask deirdre
and that a lot of people focus on
understandably are about access
interests
why do you want it what do you want what
would ideally be what you would get
what's its use what are you gonna do
with it why do you need it
um and you might that that might go up
and down you know it means less useful
you don't need it that much but it could
be useful it's relevant but it's not
necessary and and all of those debates
will lay down on your subpoena rights or
versus discovery if it's constitutional
if it's brady if it gets you to
compulsory process rights and rights to
present a defense they're
fascinating complicated issues over here
so i'm just trying to focus on this one
and say what i want for criminal
defendants is that they're not being
blocked
unnecessarily
for stupid reasons all right i mean
stupid's a little bit blunt um but we
just focus on the secrecy side if
there's a good reason
to have secrecy
then maybe some of the access interests
like the source code or
um you know
i don't know what it would be would be
less essential
and they won't defeat the good secrecy
interest
but um
whereas maybe an audit with a protective
measures uh the way
is providing us would be would be so
essential that it would defeat even a
good secrecy interest but we don't know
how to weigh those two conflicts unless
we know whether the secrecy claims are
legitimate um or not
so
so i've been trying to focus over here
maybe because this one is just so hard
to answer
great um alice any thoughts or comments
um yeah i guess maybe just going to your
original question so um yeah for me i
usually think of interpretability as a
means towards greater transparency and
accountability and i think part of
what's kind of difficult in terms of
defining
um the level of interpretability that is
appropriate for these sorts of interests
is especially when we're talking about
transparency it's really a two-sided
problem not just in terms of you know
what
um
what we are able to say about a model's
performance but what the receiving party
is able to understand based on that sort
of explanation
um and i think that creates a lot of
challenges in this area and is part of
why um historically a lot of
explainability has been used more so for
model debugging purposes rather than
actually providing transparency for
outside parties since of course if
you're the one developing the model and
you have a lot of deep knowledge about
it then it's much easier
for explainability or interpretability
to directly serve that purpose
when we talk about interpretability or
explainability or transparency more
broadly for other parties then it
becomes much more complicated since
oftentimes that receiving entity might
not
have the technical knowledge to really
consume
the sort of explanation you might have
available
or the actual answer that they need is
quite different than what you can
provide and so
to me that's kind of the challenging
bridge to
try to address in this area if we want
to actually allow interpretability to
more directly serve these interests
peter we have a question in the audience
um i have a question in the chat from
the virtual audience that i'm going to
read first and then we'll go to the in
person audience
all right
um so mario asked if there was an
independent agency that reviewed and
validated ml systems used in the
criminal justice system and rebecca i
don't know that we have time to talk
about
how evidence and technology come in
generally but i'll i'll let you do maybe
a nutshell
sure total answer is no and
yeah there's there's right there's no
and well and
mainly our reliability thresholds are
built into the adversary system on a
case-by-case basis as deirdre was
hinting at
there are some some minor exceptions uh
not for machine learning systems
specifically but nist the national
institute for standards and technology
does do some reviews of the literature
and has been written some really
important reports the national academy
of sciences as well that have raised
alarms about the validity of many
forensic systems not again not
specifically machine learning but
machine learning is involved in some of
those systems and then oddly the
national highway traffic and safety
administration audits breath test
devices again i don't think they have
machine learning in them but that's this
like one-off agency that actually has a
mandate to audit every breath test
device that police are going to use to
to you know um charge you with driving
under the influence and it's just it's
just you know curious that this is a
criminal charge
that is
frequently brought against uh white
privileged defendants and lo and behold
there's a special agency to audit that
tool um but not for anyone else
yeah i thought it was amazing when i
first started looking i was like
breathalyzers wow
gotta be really worried about those you
know
yes
um zach
hi
um thanks for all the great talks so far
so i have perhaps a bit the general
question
so
one thing that we are currently trying
all around the world is we're trying to
actually already draft legislation that
is supposed to regulate artificial
intelligence systems for example in the
european union we're trying to write
this artificial intelligence act and so
one question that i've been wondering
around and i'm a computer scientist is
if someone would ask me like what should
we write into this law
and with all the knowledge that we have
today about the technical properties of
these systems and our potential to
explain them interpret them
and the audits that we have conducted so
far
i'm still at the point where i would say
like it's really hard to say
like what what what should we write into
these laws and i would love to hear um
if you have any opinions on this in the
panel
[Music]
um i might start even though i'm the
moderator and not a panelist and um some
of you may remember the total
information awareness debacle which then
produced like these congressional
statements about banning data mining and
i was kind of like what kind of math
don't you like and
right and there's like some and
i a person like regulating ai to me is a
little bit like regulating
math or regulating a tool already and i
for the most part i think like the more
sophisticated discussions about
ai
and machine learning and the need for
different kinds of regulation are
incredibly situated within domains of
practice right so thinking about for
example if we are going to use machine
learning tools predictive machine
learning tools in the context of
clinical treatment and care right in the
health care setting
thinking about safety efficacy equity
right reliability the transference or
reliance on systems that produce
knowledge in ways that are distinct and
different from the ways in which humans
might reason from data i think you know
that's really important if we're
thinking about it in the context of
self-driving cars if we're thinking but
i i think um which doesn't i it's not
that i think the kind of regulate ai
isn't providing useful ways to think
about particular challenges that are
presented
by developments in machine learning or
developments in automation
however i think in order to really
get
into the weeds you need to be in a
domain and so i think those sorts of
conversations are much more profitable
um and i think you know rebecca's work
kind of speaks to some of that right
because different
legal domains have different demands
um you know and different kinds of
expertise and values and modes of
reasoning
and relationships to professionals and
standards of care and
adversarialism
i i don't want to jump in i want my
panelists to go first but i would i just
wanted to say georgia i'd love to hear
hear more about from you
not just as a moderator but to join us
as a panelist moving forward please but
love to hear from others
well i have a question really wonderful
talks all three of you so my question is
there's i think it was
alexander's talk about assumption that
even the platform supports the audit
that they can still use a different
algorithm
than what's being audited so
because if
there's no way of checking that part all
the auditing is just a very
superficial exercise
how would you
does it make sense actually
to still use the algorithm they gave the
auditor and run some test cases to
compare
they actually give the same around the
real platform that's the only way i can
think of sitting here to
check indirectly whether they're using
the same algorithm
i think there could be penalties in the
law so maybe in
the legislation your zac was so
contemplating for
um
for providing false information in these
kinds of audits
right like there there is a case where
the volkswagen emissions right where
they
provided false information and got
severely penalized when it was
discovered
so perhaps we can have a similar
provision here where if you agree to on
it you have to provide
the information because it's just not
possible to double check everything
like
there there has to be some some other
non-technical solution
that is helping us trust
uh what is the what is happening in the
audit
that's good to know yeah computer
security people right they talk about
you can move insecurity around but you
can't eradicate it and i think often
technologists are very interested in
not having to trust any party within a
system
and you're always going to have to be
trust are you trusting the auditor are
you trying right and and
i think the question is what are the
kind of assurances that we use to make
sure that people are behaving in ways
that
reflect the outcomes that we're trying
to assess and you're not all you're
going to have to trust somebody
at that site
at least here i'm trusting well the
editor maybe it's the wrong assumption
but to find out who is the auditor
my other question is like can you guys
compare a high level how the u.s patak
cloud compared with the um
dsa from eu who is supposed to be taking
effect next year
like are these two laws quite similar or
different
i don't think i'm familiar with the us
which which u.s law and which european
law
the platform accountability act and the
digital services act
um i'm not prepared to kind of give you
a blow by below i think sasha has
focused some on the differences in
auditing i think one of the interesting
things about
the digital services act is it requires
companies to
kind of audit to avoid systemic risks
and
there's some really like
[Music]
which how do we think about like system
level
risks and monitoring for them
um and i do think that there's like
some of some of the concerns that have
driven this interest in systemic risk
right the proliferation of false
information about elections or about
covid treatments or you know go on and
on
um those are things that occur i think
at kind of the infrastructural or
ecosystem level they're not even fully
visible even from the platform level
not that platform monitoring and
auditing can't be of value but i think
there's really interesting questions
there about
yeah
so sasha you probably have a lot more to
say about it
i i've only looked at the very specific
part that you know identifies privacy
and business of interest as a challenge
to the proposals in auditing
uh so i can't comment more broadly than
that both identify it as as a cha as a
challenge
that needs to be overcome and
both
to my computer scientists you don't
don't have a concrete solution of how to
overcome it
the other difference is that the digital
services act is
going to be implemented
hasn't yet been uh debated
uh in congress so it's not
even even though
i personally feel that it's in the very
right direction it's not clear to me
whether
it's gonna be adopted
a question or a comment uh but maybe
it's like a comment with a
invitation to push back if your
perception is something different
um alice you said that a lot of the
um sort of post-hoc interpretability
tools
are currently relegated to this sort of
more in this model debugging purpose and
the reason was because the stakeholders
there
are people who have this expert
knowledge to really understand what it
means
and i'm going to push back and say that
i think it's relegated there not because
i think they also have no idea what it
means and no one knows if any of these
things mean anything at all and the best
evidence is uh that we have nothing
concrete to say about any of them
and the reason why it's relegated there
is because the purpose they're serving
there is one for which there is no
standard
so it's sort of um they don't debug
anything
what they do is they
sort of serve a role that's sort of in
the um
you know science says given a hypothesis
how do you test it
and it doesn't tell you anything about
how you come up with a hypothesis
so i think the role they're serving
there is someone looks at the picture
and if they get some idea about what
would be an interest oh maybe the
model's doing something let me now
conduct
some kind of actually well-formed test
who's to say what is a good or a bad
source of inspiration so i think that
they're
the reason why they're there is not
because
this the recipient has specialized
knowledge such that it means something
to them
i think we equally there as everywhere
else have no reason to believe that it
means anything
but it's over there that the standard
that you have to clear is
somebody thinks it's a
interesting source of inspiration but
also if they thought that like looking
at the stars in the night was an
interesting source of inspiration
um
they're sort of open to them because
that's the bar is that low there
did you have a different sense for what
these tools provider do
um yeah i guess i would say i don't
think there's actually high standards
anywhere
necessarily i mean even if we look at
say you know the eu proposed ai which
maybe has some of the strongest
transparency requirements that we've
seen um there's not a ton of clarity yet
in terms of what exactly goes into a
conformity assessment and especially in
terms of more detailed information about
model performance since you know there's
there's certain information like you
know some information about the data
that you use to develop your model and
you know maybe like some advocacy
numbers and such but
by and large i think there's still a lot
of
lack of clarity of what would be
appropriate to put in to such an
assessment and um then what to really do
with that information in terms of um you
know at what point is that sufficient
versus not
um
and so i mean
so i i wouldn't say that the bar is so
much higher outside of folks who are
trying to debug their own models
and also i guess i would push back a
little bit in the sense that that on the
point that um interpretability or
explainability methods currently are not
useful at all for debugging
i think they're extremely limited and
oftentimes can be used to you know fool
the people who actually are trying to
use them to
better understand their own models but
um
i think you know they're better than
nothing to some extent you know if
you're for example you're using some
saliency maps to try to get some sense
of where
um your model is focusing um that's
better than maybe not using it at all as
long as you really understand the
limitations of that kind of method and
don't just take it as okay as long as my
model is not looking at um
you know information that would disclose
a sensitive attribute thus it is fair
you know that sort of
interpretation i think leads to folks
overstating what these sorts of methods
can do but
um provided you really under you you
know accept the very limited amount of
information that can be derived from
these methods hopefully it can still
provide them utility
one of the interesting
pieces of pata
is there another question okay i mean i
i i mean this all connects back to the
my earlier question to to rebecca that
you answered very well about the
knowledge required from judges i think
it kind of now puts the emphasis
on the expertise
required not from the judges but from
the
those who set the rules
i mean
sure so the
but
the legislators those who set the
regulations what kind of expertise
they have and also in in some sense i
mean they they trust
us as or us the companies whoever
develops
interpretability or
fairness notions
to to they trust what we are giving them
but we tend
to be overly optimistic or overly uh
promising about the tools that we can
provide so like what alice was just
saying i mean if you use lime or
saliency map or whatever it is very
limited in what kind of interpretation
it can give you but the people who
market it
are not so upfront about describing the
limitations and the legislators or
whoever makes
these rules are happy to assume that
there is a solution
and not probe any further so
how do we make this whole pipeline of
realizing what are the
possibilities and the limitations of the
tools how do we make it go through to
those that make the rules
well one one answer um
is
um
i have two answers one is
in the
case case-by-case adjudication context
if it's criminal or it's civil or if
it's administrative uh there's an
advantage which is a adversarialism and
b it's as applied so one of the things
that i that i get particularly worried
about
um are the rule setting or the standard
setting uh in general ex-ante um
without having um a back-end ability to
contest and challenge and scrutinize as
applied so so so maybe you're right a
company a developer over claims lime
they say can do everything it solves
everything we know exactly how these
machine learning systems work and it
doesn't really well
once you get into deploying it in an
individual case if you empower actors in
that case to expose
the the the over claiming uh then you'll
have a better chance of doing that and
you don't have to anticipate up front um
every possible way it's going to fail
that might be another answer to deirdre
your your challenging question about
whether interpretability is inherent
value or is a instrumentalist value is
it maybe it's a case-by-case
analysis but from the other perspective
of the legislatures
i just want to throw out an idea
yes
we have a huge problem that that
legislatures um you know are at
expertise deficits and resource deficits
and they're depending on a very young
staffers and uh to to work in their
offices and as a result they they're
kind of vulnerable to overclaiming and
lobbying from industry and yes i
acknowledge that um but i also want to
just throw out maybe a provocateur um
idea which is that the narrative
that i frequently hear
that lawmakers
lack
the expertise to regulate
is actually
politically powerful narrative
to discredit regulation of technology
and and and so to say well technological
change is so extraordinary and
technological expertise is so
challenging um you know yes those things
are true but in fact that's true for
lots and lots and lots of areas that
legislatures regulate all the time so i
just want us to be careful about who
politically is served by the stories we
tell and i suspect it's deregulation
advocates who like to talk about the
lack of expertise in the legislature
i just make a comment about
interpretability versus
the use of the illegal
area but i think one thing we want to
differentiate is that it's not every
interpretation method
it's trustworthy so there's also another
layer of auditing of interpretation
methods that are good authentic or not
for what situation
right there because
line might be working with other outside
information we know can trust it but i
could also introduce a further bias on
top of the algorithm itself
and that brings up like the
interpretation now for human consumption
now humans now can bring in their own
biases
so so in the end like is there something
else we can calibrate against to
we hope like diagonal create human bias
and human can correct agronomy bias by
relative to what i think that's going to
be a very hard question
how do we know
there was
like
interpreting algorithm wouldn't make it
even worse because humans now bring in
their own bias oh i don't want to use
this
variable because even legally it's okay
but somehow i know it it's not
because though therefore i don't want it
to be used i don't know how to
get out of that
kind of
corner
any thoughts about how we might in the
future
get both better
um yeah i don't have any solutions to
this but i'll just say i do think um you
know one of the big challenges in this
space which i think your question really
highlights is just how
how far away we are from the point of
really being able to say very concretely
what appropriate algorithmic audits
would be and to be able to really do
that at scale um i think you know one
hopeful thing would be you know if we
have enough transparency and
interpretability that maybe some you
know adversarial process might be able
to surface relevant factors in that way
we could maybe not have to be as
specific in terms of what exactly goes
into
any particular audit and thus
you know have legislation that's a
little bit more broad
um i i think you know it might take a
while i guess to quite get to that point
where that adversarial process and we
have you know enough case law or prior
decisions to really inform folks going
forward
um i think right now the the big
challenge that we see is you know
there's a lot of broadness in terms of
what people are calling for and
it's very hard to say how do we actually
do that in practice and the research
also i think really illustrates that and
no one really has been able to say here
is you know best practices for exactly
how you would do you know
algorithmic audits for these five models
and that's been approved by you know
some other entity
um
so i don't have any answers for how
exactly we get there except you know
maybe long term with enough examples
that have been adjudicated that might
give us some clarity
but at the moment i think the formalism
inherent in ml does create this huge
challenge in terms of making audits at
scale
i think we can learn a lot from
how
we
think about building and assessing
systems in high-stakes domains so
financial services healthcare
transportation right where
we we don't rely on interpretability we
don't rely just on kind of adversarial
audits we do everything from you know
specifications to validation and testing
to adversarial testing
to
disaster analysis which i think can be
incredibly important
um
and i think that
you know i think that there's a lot
in in listening to the presentations the
past few days i think one of the things
that really came out
is
the variety of ways in which people in
different domains are trying to build
systems or you that use machine learning
or trying to use
ml methods
in very sophisticated ways depending
upon the kind of goals values capacities
and assets they have in different areas
right so people are using causal models
and predictive models and they're going
back and forth between them
people are
using access to different kinds of
ground truth data in ways that help them
understand systems better people talked
about you know being kind of data poor
as a constant problem and ways to
navigate around that and so
i think that the same way that we see
like this real sophistication and
thinking about
how to use
in these domains
we need to bring that same level of
sophistication and thinking about how we
reflect values that are important to
those domains using a whole range of
tools that interpretability is like part
of but clearly not the entire set
great answer
um do we have more questions i think we
have time for maybe two more from the
room and then i would also of course
welcome i asked each of the panelists to
think about questions that they would
like to ask of one another and i would
be happy to open it up for that as well
i think we can progress to the
the uh
the skirmish among the panelists
i don't know if i'll have a skirmish but
um atlas why don't you start us
thanks um so
sorry let me
okay i should pull up my questions if
someone wants to go first
feel free to
sure i'll ask my question to rebecca
um
rebecca are you optimistic
that kind of the challenges that you
laid out can be
overcome
within
a reasonable time period with existing
tools or do you see a need for
new tools radically different
thinking some sort of
very big event that facilitates
change
yeah great i think that these problems
can be
reformed at least improved in the
immediate near future and a lot of the
things that i'm focused on are trying to
make legal arguments and and work with
technologists to develop new tools that
can change the salience or meeting or
possibilities of legal arguments today
right now
so it's a call to action yes we can
change things for the better um
we also need the grand visioners um but
i'm i'm not one of them i'm a small
visioner of immediately applicable um
um you know possibilities
thanks what about you thank you for the
optimism yeah yeah well yeah a little
often there's a little pessimism i think
we can do good maybe not fix everything
but a little bit of good right away
um
yeah what about from a technical
perspective does that
are you
um
thinking you'll see the changes that you
want to see in the near term or the long
term
i i think only in the long term
unless there's
a big event facilitating
my changes in the short term
questions yeah so um alexandra you you
talked a little bit about this already
in your talk but just maybe to build
upon what you already presented um what
do you think are the major properties of
social media algorithms that should be
covered um in an outside audit and what
kinds of entities do you think are best
situated in order to serve as auditors
and evaluate those properties
so i i think from the
social media algorithms
the questions that are really back to
the
social scientists and legal scholars
what do they think are the most
important
questions right obviously the question
of discrimination discrimination
uh the question of uh polarization
uh the question of
uh shaping
opinions in the way that the person is
not aware of um come to mind but
i think it's up to the broader
uh community to decide what are the most
important questions
in terms of who is well positioned to be
um
this kind of auditor frankly right now
nobody is really well positioned
uh because uh you know who
the people who are doing this kind of
work right now are journalists and
researchers
and
they have significant impediments to
their work and limitations
including
you know
financial uh limitations so i think
there needs to be
a
perhaps
policy decision to create
um
a new entity that would have
um
the incentives the legal permissions and
the financial means
uh to do this kind of work in
in the independent
uh
manner where the results are publicly
uh disseminated
i think that's kind of an interesting
just i didn't want to kind of get into
the tsa and pata but one of the
interesting aspects of pottery is that
it creates a mechanism
to study social media companies whereby
independent researchers can submit
research proposals to nsf
and if those are approved social media
companies are supposed to provide the
necessary information subject to
security and privacy requirements
and companies that fail to comply could
be subject to ftc enforcement or and
also potentially
lose section 230 immunity which
everybody seems to know about section
230 so i won't talk about it a little
bit
and it also provides some safe harbor
protection for researchers
um
and i think like
it's interesting to think about you know
like nsf is supposed to create process
and guidelines and criteria and like
what criteria makes sense and
who at nsf is going to do the job of
creating those process and guidelines
and criteria
um and just like which questions are
good i don't i don't know and i i think
the question of like
is it a new entity that does this or is
it using all of the existing research
talent that exists and figuring out ways
to kind of
create structures that
encourage or require
different kinds of research to be
supported
that platforms and you could think about
scaling this to other kinds right all of
the technology used in the criminal
justice system potentially right would a
similar model
where if you're going to be used in the
criminal justice system you have to have
the capacity to allow
for
academics to pro independent researchers
to get clearance to study what it is
that you're doing and how these things
function
um and so it's an interesting way of
like not creating like a specialized
team but
benefiting from all the kinds of
questions that researchers might think
are worth asking
i do think that this runs in also just
an interesting point that i really
appreciate sasha putting a pin in like
whose questions would be asked then
right like if i see one more study about
like how much disinformation there is
i'm like is that really the question we
want to answer like
um and i think kind of social scientists
legal scholars have might have different
ideas about the kinds of questions that
would help us design better systems or
better understand problems then machine
learning or cs research is kind of
operating on their own and so thinking
about like what kind of criteria
might guide that um because we you know
first come first serve we could we could
have like
i don't know you know there's only so
much research that's probably going to
be able to be supported
i think somebody uh anzu has a question
i'm not sure i'm seeing it oh there it
is great um this is from kevin stengel
um
he missed some of the talks so if this
was already discussed he's sorry but do
you guys have any thoughts on how the
u.s census bureau has published its own
privacy audits in response to its legal
duties to maintain privacy
for me it's an interesting precedent for
privacy aware data analysis and research
that could inform other auditing
scenarios and kevin are you talking in
specifically about all of the various
work that they've done around the
implementation of differential privacy
um i too yeah so i i don't know whether
or not all of you have been following
this i assume sasha probably has and i
assume alice and rebecca you're probably
like what
um
but
one of the things that's very
interesting is i said we've seen this
handoff right
historically census has used a range of
statistical disclosure limitation
techniques to meet their
obligation to limit the availability the
availability for taxpayers to be
sorry for citizens to be identified
and
they
realized in part by
due to research by people in this
community um and certainly in the
differential privacy community that the
statistical disclosure limitation
techniques they were using were not fit
for purpose and so they realized that in
order to provide meaningful data they
needed to shift over to use differential
privacy
and this has become kind of like an
enormous political storm and part of
that i think is about and they have used
kind of every technique in the book to
make information about their choices and
what they're doing available however
their constraints like they can't make
the noisy measurements available which
means that differential privacy experts
can't actually figure out whether or not
it's good privacy
and they can't make they can't make
baseline data available for people to
understand how much noise is being
infused and therefore there's many
people who don't trust that the noise is
what they say it is and so they have
been
enormously like they've engaged in an
enormous process to try to help people
understand the choices that they're
making and in many ways dp allows them
to be much more transparent about the
choices they're making than
statistical disclosure limitations that
they've used in the past which rely on
secrecy
um to avoid disclosures and it's been
it's been really like
you know the magnificence of a disaster
man and there's litigation and there's
and i think it's truly fascinating and
really underscores some of the
complexities
of trying to
build both trustworthy and trusted
systems that rely on algorithms that
many people do not understand and and
implementations of of um technical
definitions so sasha to you
i
i agree with what you said teacher and
uh to the question i would add yes it is
a very
interesting and very
noble example of how one does its own
privacy audit
and how one is transparent about the
limitations of current techniques and
then uses those studies in order to
explain why the new techniques are
needed
and i personally think that those audits
are
very good motivation for why
differential privacy is needed in the
senses
but i don't know if this can be a
blueprint for other types of
self-audits because the u.s census
bureau is not in the business of making
money from
violating people's privacy
and so they can
improve the privacy of their systems
potentially without
business costs there are other costs
that teacher talked about
but there is not a business cost and uh
i i don't see the same kind of audit
being done by
entities who are in the business of
uh
making money from private data
and that can go to also other places
like algorithmic fairness right if if
your business fundamentally is making
money from discrimination
i i don't know that you're going to be
in the position until
be making audits and making them
publicly available
about
whether your systems are
non-discriminatory and whether those
audits without
a third party involved they're gonna be
trustworthy
i know
sorry to jump in but i think we have to
finish with 15 minutes and the lunch is
outside for us
great it has been a really fascinating
discussion and talks so maybe
[Applause]
thank you so much this was a pleasure
um thank you sasha alice and rebecca for
joining and thank you ben and zach for
reminding me that you guys might want to
eat
well thank you let me just um stand up
with zach to finish his workshop
officially so
i really had a great time of course we
also on the organizer so let's probably
we should have some objective
evaluations later
but i'd like to thank the staff for
their support especially um
[Music]
and kalani who is now here who has been
always supporting us throughout the
whole process and
hope the discussion will continue for
the long-term visitors and then zach
will probably have his comments yeah um
as also there you know
i think
then for who's uh
[Music]
you know um by far the more on top of uh
everything than me uh and a good mentor
um
and uh shai and ruth who uh approached
us i think over three years ago
yeah other community members of the
workshop
for for this the very cluster existing
uh been uh
keeping this torch alive for uh a
tremendous amount of time so
yeah let me just mention the other uh
workshop committee member so this was
planned two years ago and we recognized
the coach here and we also have deidre
on the community hema who can make it
and david madigan so actually we kind of
revamped everything kind of restarted
more recently but they're also on the
committee so we should thank them as
well
and then she's outside hike will be led
by zach
where's zach gonna hike
nice videos
and i should get together with deirdre
so nice to see you congratulations to
alessandra for a new job and alice i
hope i see you